all right we are now live for the First
Philosophy pop up for December 2018 and
as I am slowly getting myself unburied
from lots and lots and lots of grading
and dealing with with student issues for
the five classes I've been teaching this
semester I thought that a good topic
since its you know tough lesson for me
is student success and you know when I
talk about student success I don't just
think about well what makes students
successful but also the things that
stand in the way of students being
successful so you know obstacles to
students experiencing success or having
success or continuing to have success
for that matter and then you know
various issues that that tend to arise
I'm not I'm not the kind of person who
tends to complain a lot about about
students you know it with this sort of
generational thing that that I see quite
a few instructors doing and talking
about you know new generations is having
less capacities than the earlier ones
because I think back to my college days
and there were plenty of my peers who
you know as students were kind of
slouches we're not doing a good job and
I would look at them and be like you
know what what's wrong with with your
approach to this sort of stuff why do
you even want everything made easier
dumbed down or you know why can't you
just study the material and I don't
think that there's a greater proportion
of students today who are not as well
prepared I think at least for from my
experience there were just as many back
then and when I say prepared I don't
just mean in terms of like academic or
cognitive you know things I'm talking
about behavioral things right
assumptions that are made or ways that
people do things
how they you know how they work at stuff
how they plan their day how they manage
time all of those sorts of issues but I
think that there are some new challenges
I think I would say that the
availability of the internet probably
raises the stakes for people who don't
have very good time management
capacities and you know maybe also on
the professor's sides right because
there's there's you know professors have
a lot more work that they have to do
with committees than assessment and
things like that and and maybe the
stakes are raised a little bit for how
they should prepare their class in terms
of using the course management system
and having assignments posted ahead of
time so I don't think that we're in a
radically new situation you know for
millennial students or the generation
that's coming up now after the
Millennials as a matter of fact I will
say this that I teach a lot of
professional students who are older they
they're people who have been working for
a while and I see the same sort of
mistakes being made and not accessing
the course materials until the last
minute and excuses and you know
expectations of getting some sort of
points for effort I see that the same
from 40-somethings
as at you from 20-somethings or or
teenagers I don't think it's a radically
new issue that we're we're facing looks
like there's some some questions here
already being posed but looks like some
of them are a little less relevant than
others I'm actually gonna take this one
from Kannagi can a Glen Koenig Alvey and
then I'll jump back into talking about
like you know Student Success so
they observe I think a lot of students
miss out on some educational tools older
people got like shorthand or certain
memory techniques I would even put Greek
and Latin in that same category so I
know I didn't learn shorthand and you
know there there are some things that
are not being taught as often that were
taught you know like writing in cursive
for example but I don't know that that
makes a big difference
now memory techniques I think that
depended totally on who is teaching you
and where you were going to school we
didn't really learn much of that in my K
through 12 or undergraduate education
and what memory techniques we used in
graduate school we really can't had to
learn on our own Greek and Latin we are
many generations here in the United
States past times when you could expect
that somebody would have Greek or Latin
in there K through 12 or college
education I think most most people are
lucky if they're learning one foreign
language it you know and oftentimes
you're restricted to just Spanish you
know Latin French German those are
pretty much fallen by the wayside so I
don't know that that's really the case
in any sort of you know broad
comparative way maybe maybe it's more
like that in Europe that there's been a
decline in that but I think that that
you are right that a lot of students
miss out on educational tools but
nowadays we have so many more
educational tools available to us if we
want to use them and the Internet is
just vastly opened up capacities for
that and in several different ways one
is you know for if I'm teaching a class
every college class that I teach I have
a course management system and it could
be you know blackboard or Moodle or
Sakai or d2l or canvas I've used even a
few other
more obscure ones but they all have the
same base of capacities right you can
create modules with lesson pages upload
files have the readings available shoot
videos if you want that you can upload
or at least link to from YouTube
podcasts you can you know aggregate
links for the students and and good
teachers they actually do that and they
create quizzes online that you can use
to check your your knowledge and they
create learning opportunities like
discussion forums and and I do that
that's what that's why for me it's
pretty easy to transition from
face-to-face to online teaching because
every one of my face-to-face classes is
halfway online right now a lot of
teachers don't do that and so if you're
a student and your teacher hasn't given
you the resources then you have to look
online yourself and I guess for some
topics and some thinkers there's not a
lot available right you know in
philosophy for example there's you know
lots of stuff available say on Descartes
although a lot of it's not particularly
good but maybe there's not much
available on more obscure philosophers
like chef stuff right so you know you
you have to kind of look around but but
maybe you don't look for videos maybe
you look for podcasts maybe you look for
encyclopedia entries maybe you look for
other resources but the point is you can
find a lot of stuff out there to help
you and you know in other fields as well
it does require what some of what we
call information literacy and that
that's something important to teach as
well how do you tell the the good
sources from the sources that are not so
so good how do you do that especially as
somebody who's not an expert and doesn't
quite know what they're getting into
those are good questions but you know if
you have access to the Internet you
actually have access to all sorts of
resources and
I think it's up to students to take an
active role in their own learning and
not be very passive and expectant you
know the instructor to provide all the
resources that said you know you
shouldn't be like in my classes if I
give you Plato to read I don't want you
using sparknotes as a substitute for
actually reading the Plato because then
you know I should have just given you
the sparknotes to begin with and said
well we're not we're not gonna really
read philosophy here we're just gonna
read some summaries of it written by
some people who read philosophy that's
not the way I do things but that's
because I consider my students capable
of actually reading philosophy right
wherever they happen to be so alright
let's go back and look at some of these
other questions
made of clay and 21 I'm about to start
college just now and I'm going for
philosophy though there's that thought
in the back of my head that it's useless
even though I really love it can you
encourage me it's not useless people
with philosophy degrees
work in all sorts of fields there's some
things that are sort of a natural spin
off if you're planning on going to law
school and you're gonna take the LSAT
being a philosophy major great way to
have a high LSAT score because you're
working with arguments all the time but
you know there's all sorts of other
areas it's just that you you just can't
expect that because you've got a diploma
somebody's automatically going to hire
you have to develop certain skills in
certain capacities and you have to be
able to make the case for why the things
you've been studying in philosophy
actually connect up with real life
issues and problems and how you can be
you know if you want people to hire you
and you've got to make some sort of case
for why you're bringing value to them I
think and I think that's perfectly
reasonable for them to ask that you know
but it's it's it's feasible to do
there's plenty of success stories out
there that you can you can look at of
people who have taken philosophy degrees
and done quite well and and are still
applying philosophy and
in the course of their lives or their
careers so hopefully that that provides
you with some encouragement
Abdullah asked as studying philosophy
require a lot of memorization I don't
think it does but different students
have different approaches some students
love to memorize things I'm the kind of
person who was very uninterested even
when I was learning languages in just
memorization I wanted to understand why
things work the way they did and then
derive what ought to be the case from
from that you know learning the larger
system or the bigger picture as we say
but if you're the kind of person who
likes to memorize things and and that's
your approach then you know maybe you'll
do that I mean I think you can learn
about the history of philosophy best in
some ways by just reading a lot in the
history of philosophy reading the actual
source texts and then you know what
Plato thought about something or what
Descartes thought about something and
and you could memorize that I guess if
you want to but if you if you work at it
enough you don't have to memorize it you
develop a sort of affinity or you know a
con naturality with it it becomes part
of you right becomes part of your your
mind and then that sticks with you
probably better than stuff that you just
memorize and who asks is there any way
to be sure of not misinterpreting
philosophers excluding secondary
literature and stuff alike probably not
you're probably going to misinterpret
you know when you're first studying
given text especially if you haven't
been studying philosophy that long
you're probably gonna misinterpret some
things right and some of it'll just be
an electrical level we're tracking
yesterday a friend of mine and I about
the issue of false cognates right when
you're reading a text and there's a term
and we use that term one way and it was
used a different way back then it means
something different that's that's
something you have to be attentive to
and you might screw things up by you
know not knowing that but and that's
okay you know I mean it's not as if you
have to be perfect in your understanding
of philosophy at every moment especially
when you're starting out at a beginner
intermediate level it's not even as if I
have to you know as an expert know
everything and be completely right about
everything that's that that's not a
requirement in order to to do philosophy
well you know most of the most of
philosophy is kind of an iterative
process you you study something and try
to apply it and ask other people about
it and realize you've got some of it
wrong and then go back to it and get a
little bit more right a little bit more
or right a little bit more right and
that's okay let's see here memento mori
I'm a law student and I hate it as much
as I look philosophy that's very
unfortunate I would love to join a
master's program in philosophy but my
GPA is bad but I keep publishing
philosophy articles you know I would say
you finish the law degree it's always
nice to have a law degree you can do
things with it it's not as if you have
to get all your degrees out of the way
as a young person right away and yeah I
mean I suppose some master's programs a
low GPA could be a real problem but you
know oftentimes you can write an essay
that explains your particular case and
say oh I'd like an exception to be made
I've done this you know I've done that
here's why my case even though I've got
a low GPA here's why you should you
should consider me you know I imagine
that the GRE is still for American
programs at least considered quite
important but I mean the cool thing is
is that I pointed this out in the past
before we don't have a unified system we
have like a patchwork
all these different universities and
programs and there's some
generalizations you can make but they
differ from each other
considerably right so you could you know
you could find one that that's that's
well suited to what you want to study
and that will let you in and let you do
what you want to do all right Tom eight
has a question that I'm not gonna have
it a very interesting answer for you
said once in an AMA that you've tried
the drug ecstasy has that experience
change your perspective on the world in
any way can you tell us about that
experience no because it didn't really
do anything for me I was you know this
is back in the 90s and I was I was
drinking and we were having a good time
and I only you know I did that that once
and didn't really pay that much
attention to it so certainly didn't
change my life in any important way you
know I don't think here's what I would I
have to say there's I get a lot of
questions about about various drugs and
stuff like that there are people who
think that by taking drugs you like open
your mind or you know do things that
allow you to connect with the the cosmos
or reality better and maybe that's true
to some extent but if that's the case
then they're a crutch a chemical crotch
and you can do that with other things as
well and it wouldn't be better just to
like cultivate your mind to the point
where you could you could do that sort
of thing I mean you say well ecstasy
will allow you to be closer with other
people and to put up with their [ __ ]
better yeah so we'll virtue ethics if
you practice it so I you know I'm not an
I I've had some friends who are really
big into taking different things and
experimenting with them but I never
found I never found that very very
interesting
Oh memento has a follow-up what would
you advise me to do to increase my
chances of getting admitted and even
finding some scholarship for school fees
after I graduate well like I said if
we're talking about the American context
I don't think that there's you know a
blueprint because the programs are very
different from each other I would say
you know think about the essay that
you're gonna write and submit about why
you want to go there and I would you
know if I were you and I wanted to go to
a particular program I'd start making
contacts with them you know writing some
of the professor's and if possible
meeting some of them scholarships you
know that completely depends on the
institution some some places give you
funding other places don't have much
funding and it's up to them how they
allocate it so you would you'd want to
ask somebody who's in that department
how it works with that but yeah there's
not much else that I think that you
could say that's helpful in that Alright
Tiberio I've read Georgina's father and
sons bizarre offs characters of
self-proclaimed Nia lists even though
the book takes place around 1850 Athan
the book very prophetic because I've
seen a lot could you comment on that
this new self program proclaimed Neela's
generation that chooses to deny
everything in order not to respect it
yeah you kneel this by the way is an
equivocal term or polysemic term it
doesn't have just one single meaning the
Russian Nia lists were not exactly the
same thing as Nietzsche's diagnosing as
kneel ISM let alone what people are
sometimes calling it today so you always
want to ask when somebody says I'm an
a-lister I'm advocating nihilism you got
it or I'm against kneel ISM guess so
what exactly do you mean by that
and the the knee lists that were in
Russia most of them were wiped out by
the way
yeah so that's one reason they didn't
continue to have a great effect on
history you know they were committed to
a kind of social progress but without
that kind of underpinning of the
Enlightenment and they were very much
against the conventions that were deeply
rooted in Russian society at the time
even as it's starting to unravel it's a
great book I love turgenyev and I really
enjoy that that particular book myself I
think Virginia in writing that places
himself up in the pantheon of great
dialogic Russian writers like Dostoevsky
for example so I I went through a period
back when I was an undergraduate where I
was reading my greenie reading my way
through anything Russian I could get my
hands on because it turned out they had
such cool writers so I was reading a lot
of Trajan yeah I'm go go and push kin
and and read all those social needs and
stuff that's much later you know read my
way through Dostoevsky and and I really
you know I was having a good time with
with that um but that that's a book that
I particularly liked and I'd recommend
it it's well worth the read if you
haven't read George Aeneas father and
sons fathers and sons then it's you
should check it out
Sebastian how did you become a
philosophy professor what advice would
you give someone looking for a career in
academia or philosophy I've got a whole
video on advice about becoming a
philosophy professor and I'd say most of
that I would still stand by today it's a
tough gig and you know I'll give you
sort of one little bit from that go to
the highest tier school that you can
afford because the job the job market is
really terrible and it's going to
continue to remain terrible for
academics in general and for philosophy
in particular
and whether we like it or not or think
that it's fair people from top tier
universities even if they're not
particularly good often get the job over
people from middle tier universities
even if they're really good that's just
the way the game works you know and
there's a lot of reasons for that we
could go into how did I become a
philosophy professor well that's kind of
a funny story I mean I sort of stumbled
into philosophy by chance and stuck with
it and then you know finished my
undergraduate with a degree in
philosophy and mathematics and had to
decide what do I want to do and even at
that time I still wasn't even thinking
about well what am I gonna do with a
degree eventually I just want to know
should I go to graduate school for
philosophy because they really like
philosophy and wanted to study more
should I go for mathematics which I also
very much liked or should I take the
actuarial exams a nice safe path and
have a reliable very low stress job and
while I was making that decision I was
working here in Milwaukee just blocks
from where we currently live in a
building called a hundred East building
as a third shift security guard and
reading a lot of philosophy and working
at my foreign languages and I decided I
would apply for you know graduate school
in philosophy and then I you know
settled it in to southern Illinois
because they offered me the most money
the quickest and I liked it and just
kept going with it and then it got to
the point where we're you know I had to
start thinking about what am I going to
do after I get this degree and
philosophy professor was a viable option
I was already you know publishing at the
time I was you know doing pretty pretty
good teaching work and stuff like that
building up my Vita and I was fortunate
and that I found a job the you know
first job was teaching in a
maximum-security prison I did that for
six years and then I
move to Fayetteville State University
where I was a professor there and then
left to come up to New York to be with
my my then that time fiancé not wife and
then I you know became part-time and
started doing other things on the side
so my career trajectory is not one that
I think a lot of people could imitate
and I don't know that it's particularly
illustrative to talk about it but that's
that's okay Joe asks I'm third year
University having real trouble writing
essays I can fully understand content
but my writing I think lets me down any
tips well you know you could you could
think about breaking the writing down
into manageable chunks think about you
know sort of mapping it out and I'm not
talking about like a traditional outline
but more like like an actual just map of
things you think about well what is what
is what am I trying to get across in
this essay what what are the criteria
that I need to meet from my instructor
who's requiring me to write it what
points do I need to make and then you
start working backwards from that and
start thinking okay what can I do with
the materials that I've got how can I
demonstrate the things that I need to
demonstrate and and I would say you know
write your introduction and your
conclusion last work on the content
stuff the introduction you know that's
the thing to finish at the end don't
don't try to you know write a big
promissory note at the beginning that
you might not be able to live up to and
then you feel bad about it just you know
write an introduction that summarizes
what you actually did manage to pull off
in the paper that's that's the way to do
it and and I again do it in manageable
chunks you know sometimes people try to
just sit down and write a paper in in
one sitting and some people can pull
that off but others need to do it piece
by piece by piece and so that that could
be helpful
all right drew looks like we have a lot
of questions and topics here so
[Applause]
subconscious qualms what notion of God
do you find the most convincing God as a
being or God is being itself well I I
guess I you know I'm more traditionally
plainest in that way it sort of
Christian you know Jewish Muslim even
you know some respect some some pagan
neoplatonist were like that I think it
makes makes more sense to talk about God
as being then as a single being an
entity so made of clay what are your
thoughts on rick roderick i think it's
unfortunate he died pretty high you know
because i like i like his uh talks that
it that he's given that we still have
it's fortunate that somebody recorded
them it seems like a pretty cool guy but
they had to forget how i think he died
of a heart attack or something and he
wasn't it wasn't that much older i think
then i currently am now so all right one
two three duck does contemporary market
society promote or a road virtue in your
view what readings are papers in this
area would you recommend so two
different things there if we think about
it in terms of like let's let the market
decide or anything along those lines
then i think that in a roads don't you
and that was I mean that was the issue
even back in in ancient Greece you know
you see Plato and Aristotle and the
Stoics talking quite a bit about this do
we put up you know moral conceptions
just to a kind of popular vote whether
it's voting in you know the the the
forum or voting in the marketplace no
because that's not how we actually
determine those things and anybody who
thinks that that's how you determine
them that's exactly the kind of person
you want to keep out of that vote
because because they they don't
understand those sorts of issues and
there's plenty of other aspects of
market society that that make things
difficult I mean if you're having to
work your butt off in crappy
circumstances and eat crap from people
all day long it's gonna be tougher for
you to cultivate the virtues because
you're starting out at a much you know
tougher place then then other people who
are in a much more privileged position
but it doesn't make it impossible
now what readings are papers in this
area would you recommend I don't know I
mean you could start with you know stuff
from Plato and Aristotle onward you know
go all the way through looking at
political economy and sort of you know
Marxist analysis of that and then you
know you could look at somebody like
Alistair McIntyre who who effectively
runs the whole gamut of that and who is
quite interested in those those sorts of
issues and there's so many people out
there who who has something to say about
these these matters the one thing that I
would say that I think could be quite
helpful is when you're looking at older
discussions and models like think about
Adam Smith right and the invisible hand
Adam Smith's invisible hand was not
intended to apply to late capitalism as
a justification for Amazon doing
whatever the hell it wants right it was
you know they're it's a conception that
that has been greatly abused by many
people to argue for all sorts of things
that are sort of deleterious over time
likewise de Tocqueville who I'm going to
be recording a podcast on later on this
week with a friend and colleague of mine
his notion about you know the the small
businessperson and and you know
voluntary or intermediate associations
and you know learning how to manage
things that's not the modern corporate
nor is it even the modern educational
institution you have to do a lot of work
to adapt these ideas from previous times
to the present and it's not impossible
work but it is work you can't just like
you know suck up a thing here and just
plop it right down over here and think
that it's going to automatically connect
up that that's how you generate ideology
right a la brick let's see when we study
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit to
acquire full knowledge about the
condition of Hegel's air and his
personal life conflicts I wouldn't study
the phenomenology for that I mean Hegel
doesn't mention hardly any anything by
name in the phenomenology has to do so
many connecting things up I mean you
want to know about angles era and and
Hegel's life conflicts read biographies
of Hegel that's probably gonna be a hell
of a lot more helpful than trying to
tease it out of the phenomenology you're
just not gonna I mean you're not gonna
tease it out of any of it this works I
think quite frankly so yeah I would I
would I would look for biographies now
which is a good biography I don't know I
haven't read any of that sort of stuff
for years and years because I'm not I'm
not that interested in the biography of
Hegel I'm more interested in unpacking
the thought in his works so all right
philosopher Greg nice name there
what is the cutting edge of philosophy
today I don't know I mean I don't think
there is a cutting edge of philosophy
today that implies that there's like
some sort of consensus about you know
where progress is actually taking place
and and the field the way we have it you
can't stay on top of even a fraction of
the contemporary developments you can
only like focus on a few areas and
there's a lot of as there are at every
era there's a lot of sort of
flash-in-the-pan faddish people who are
big now because people are buying their
books or or you know reading
and talking about them who are just
going to be footnotes 30 40 years from
now and only antiquarians are going to
be looking at their their stuff but it's
tough to tell sometimes who's who right
so yeah all right Joe bowler is some
stuff to Allah brick about Hegel well
one was how do you reconcile your
Christian worldview with the fact that
Lemmy is God well you know that's that's
that's sort of a work in progress I
don't think Lemmy is God I think let me
was was a amazing musician and I really
sad that he's gone you know but you know
we're just sort of joke about that that
sort of thing you know it's funny
because I when I was young if you were
to ask me like 18 year old Greg who's
your who's your favorite metal band I
would have said unhesitatingly Iron
Maiden right Motorhead it is is probably
on the same rank for me as Iron Maiden
is there certainly in the top tier along
with Judas Priest and and you know quite
a few other bands who I keep going back
to over and over again going into their
catalogue yeah alright so rave Junior
not a question just wanted to thank you
for being you and helping me
tremendously in my life very nice I'm
glad that the videos have been useful
for you I always like to know that
they're having some positive effect
otherwise it's sort of like throwing
messages in too many bottles yeah let's
see here alright there's some back and
forth between Alan and Joe that I'm
gonna skip over Sebastian I very much
enjoy many of the lecture series you've
uploaded I was wondering if you could do
a series on maralell Ponte so we're
talking about Maurice Marilyn
the phenomenologist studied with who
Cyril taken by many of the early French
readers before hosts all got translated
and they realized how different he was
from metal 20 to be sort of the faithful
transmitter of host roles ideas but well
worth reading in his own right both for
his you know massive work the
phenomenology of perception also for
many of his essays and even for his
later work the visible and the invisible
yeah he's somebody I haven't read for
quite a while I used to used to be quite
into Merril upon teen and part because
my mentor Garth Gillan was was a Marilyn
Ponte scholar but you know he's somebody
I'd like to go back to I don't know if
I'd enjoy him as much going back now I
remember really enjoying like the
phenomenology perception in the
structure of comportment and some of
these other works and and really the
video production the things that are
driving it are what I need for my
students for my classes a lot of the
core concept videos what people have an
interest in the half hour Hegel the big
commitment I made there that I'm trying
to fulfill and then what people are are
demanding I do do commissioned videos if
you want to like speed things up but you
know it's always a matter of finding
time that's that can be quite tough all
right John plants do I have an
alternative way of supporting my work
I'm suspicious of patreon do you think
it's censorship is politically motivated
yeah I think it's censorship it's
politically motivated but I don't care
because everybody's politically
motivated and nobody's pure in that
respect and you know they're a business
like anyone else so sargon of akkad
wants to violate the things that they
decide to be the rules and he gets stung
tough you know I actually lost a few
patrons patreon supporters who are like
oh you you've got rid of Sargon and you
know it's in the exit interview and I'm
like I get rid of them patreon did I
don't know why you're taking it out on
me yeah people can contribute through
PayPal PayPal has got its own political
stuff you're not going to find a
platform that doesn't that's all that's
all there is to save I mean do you know
how I how I mostly support my work with
my business and my clients and you know
my teaching for academic institutions
because patreon is is is nice but it's
not like I'm you know setting the world
on fire with it's up yeah I mean you get
what you get all right it's not like
it's not like we're gonna get patreon to
change whatever biases they have so you
work with the imperfect world we have
Damon how do I know if grad school and
philosophy is right for me oh that's a
good question
so think about whether you want to in
effect put your financial life on hold
for anywhere from two to seven years and
possibly go into debt and balance that
against what it is that you you want to
study intensively in graduate school and
what you think the degree at the end is
going to provide you with what
opportunities and you have to think
about this very very realistically you
know you can't think about this in a
sort of optimistic idealist you know
this is all gonna work out kind of sense
because that's all people crash and burn
you need to think about what are the
odds of my actually finding a position
that is going to use this degree because
you have to earn a living
unless you're independently wealthy I
mean if you have a trust fund that's a
whole different question right but if
you don't like the rest of us then
you've got to be very you know prudent
about these matters
dadoo two thoughts on Oswald Spengler
haven't read him for a long long time
you know he's got that whole decline of
the West idea and that's pretty much it
so maybe I'll go back to him sometime I
don't know all right
made of clay maybe you've answered this
question before but as joyed Peterson's
taken post-modernism as a whole somewhat
accurate though I know he generalizes it
greatly yet people seem to believe him
well people believe all sorts of
[ __ ] up there don't think so
who cares if people seem to believe him
people believe all sorts of crazy stuff
that's not a criterion that by itself of
course doesn't mean that he's wrong but
you don't use it as a criterion for him
being right Peterson doesn't know what
he's talking about when it comes to
post-modernism unfortunately he's using
the term in a very sloppy broad sense he
well I'll put it to you this way either
he does know better in which case he is
deliberately misleading people or he
doesn't know better in which case he
shouldn't talk about it and he's not you
know he's not unique there's many many
other people who are doing that as well
or talking about deconstruction or think
that somehow Derrida managed to infect
the culture you know it's just terrible
his history of ideas
unfortunately so yeah and that's really
all I need to say I've said plenty about
Peterson in the past all right um let's
see here more stuff back and forth ah
Jake Ramsay can better philosophy
substitute the work of psychology or in
what ways do these disciplines cooperate
or intersect with regards to helping
people psychology is not a unified field
so that right there is you can't really
ask about psychology as as such if
you're talking about psychotherapy right
or a counseling psychology or you know
whatever we're gonna frame it as can
philosophy substitute for that for some
people yes for some other people No
somebody has is really diagnosed with
severe depression and needs medication
doesn't matter how many you know things
you you have them read and how long you
discuss applying stoic principles or
Aristotelian teleology or dentist
philosophy you're not going to get them
to feel better but it can be very very
helpful in in many other circumstances
right or if somebody's sick hack that's
that's not for the the realm of
philosophy and it's not even for the
realm of most psychologists right I
would say that that good psychologists
understand that psychology came out of
philosophy and they do their best to try
to incorporate insights from philosophy
into psychology and if you know the
history of psychology you know that that
that is in fact the case all right
not just in terms of psychotherapeutic
approaches but even in Experimental
Psychology or or you know more
theoretical things very often they they
can work together but then you have to
be able to do this interdisciplinary
work and most people are not that good
at that but you know yeah it can be
quite helpful
alright Neela and Annie could you please
give me any advice about studying
philosophy I'm an English major want to
continue my studies in philosophy also
how to understand it fully well I mean
the last one expect to put in a lot of
time and expect it to be an iterative
process i I can't even say that I
understand all the people that I teach
fully but I but I don't need to right so
don't try to hold yourself to an
impossible to meet standard studying
philosophy there's there's no substitute
for actually reading the primary texts
and that has to be the thing that you go
back to over and over again you can use
resources ranging from videos and
podcasts you know sort of multimedia
things to popular summaries to
all sorts of other things in between but
you you can't study plate it without
reading Plato you can't study Hegel
unfortunately because Hegel is not a
good writer and it's very difficult to
work with without reading Hegel there's
there's no way around it and that's the
centerpiece you're gonna expect to go
back to it over and over again and I
would say you know can I give you any
any useful advice yeah
don't try to boil the ocean you don't
need to study everybody you don't need
to read every single thing that's
available find some things that you
actually resonate with at the current
stage that you're you're at and study
those and derive some enjoyment from it
you know and and don't don't put these
impossible to meet demands on yourself
that will make you feel crappy about the
activity that should be a joyous
activity and an exciting activity take
what you can you know and then if you
read Plato and you're like this stuff is
just not resonating with me it might be
that it doesn't resonate with you now
and ten years from now you'll read it
and have a very different experience and
that's okay you know I can tell you from
experience myself that I didn't
understand probably three-quarters of
what this reading is an undergraduate
and there are a lot of philosophers who
I read who I love now like Aristotle
first couple times I read Aristotle's
like wow this is mind-numbing ly boring
stuff why do I have to read this who the
hell thought this was good you know and
now I know I'm an Aristotle scholar and
I teach them all the time but you know
so it takes it takes a while so maybe
that'll be helpful advice for you
hopefully all right Marco Felice good to
see you so he says is there a similarity
between the state agencies of multiple
facets of one's character thinking of a
Plato's Republic in the fractured state
of the soul yeah so you know Plato I
don't think he really meant that the you
know the the tribe part
take soul you know meaning you've got
the the craftspeople really everybody
else right here comes everybody
you've got the craftspeople as the
bottom part and then you've got like the
brains the Guardians the decision-makers
at the top the political leaders then
you've got this military slash police
slash whatever [ __ ] may be firefighters
people who need courage to do their work
class I don't think that's a blueprint
for how he thought of society in general
because it doesn't actually map on some
of the other dialogues and certainly
full you know society is more
complicated than that isn't it you know
you look at Aristotle Aristotle is going
to distinguish like a whole bunch of
different organs and functions of the
state but Plato's tripartite psychology
I think can be quite useful and it was
used by a lot of later writers you know
it's it's you know it provides a lot of
helpful insights I would say now the
fractured stay in the soul right so most
of us are not well integrated from
Plato's perspective because then the the
top part the the intellectual or the
rational part of the soul should be
dominating telling the middle part the
part that is the energy that part that's
concerned social status part that gets
angry what to do and that enforces it's
its laws upon the appetites which
otherwise cannot control themselves I
think many of us are you know pretty
fractured when it comes to that and
there's other ways of understanding the
fractured nough some our selves - can we
map that on to cultures or societies yes
but we got to be we've got to be kind of
careful it's not as if in most cases we
have a psychology of a whole
city or state or or even corporation
where the the parts of it represent
these different functions and they're
divided against each other like that
it's usually more complex so but it's
good to see you Marco Cody I can't help
but shake the notion that hedonism being
pleasure and the reduction of pain is
the good I see an Aristotle and Plato
for instance and the end of Plato's the
myth of Earth seems to me to me Plato
arguing for good in this life will
choose the right life to live in the
next life to reduce suffering and
maximize pleasure well sort of I mean
it's not just about you know maximizing
pleasure it's about actually living a
life that's decent and enjoyable because
you're able to use your faculties and so
it's not so I mean you have to have a
very reductive reading to read Aristotle
or Plato as hedonist
and you have to go against so many
things that they actually say in their
texts aerosol Aristotle's clear
pleasures are good it's not that good
all right
and people think says people who think
that it is the good there's something
wrong all right so I don't even have to
you'd have to deal with that problem
wouldn't you
Proform or famine do you like the
Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
online it's you know it's okay
I like the fact that it exists sort of
like the internet encyclopedia of
philosophy some of the articles are
great some of the articles not so great
useful resource glad that that they
organized it yeah oh as a tool for
teaching help I mean I mean I I
sometimes suggest articles to my
students but I find that the stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy is usually
written at such a level that the
undergrad a average an undergraduates do
can't get that much out of it internet
encyclopedia of philosophy sometimes
better in that respect and they vary in
quality right you know sometimes the IEP
articles better better research
sometimes the SE p one is alright dad do
to what's the relevance of Spangler
today Spengler's probably my biggest
intellectual influence well I don't
think he has much relevance today quite
frankly and I think that you know we we
need to be aware of you know cultural
prophets that had it all figured out and
actually look at the situation that
we're in if he's your biggest
intellectual influence you know you
might want to check out lots of other
people too so yeah
JP fanboy have you ever read any Gaston
Bachelard I'm just getting into the
poetics of space and digging it yeah I
read him a long time ago but I didn't
really get into him so I didn't keep up
with it
Bertrand Bertrand Walla was Catholic
philosopher do you think the Pope should
be philosophically sophisticated like
Benedict the 16th and john paul ii i
mean i don't describe myself as a
Catholic philosopher in the sense of
like you know the churches you know bank
bankrolling or giving the imprimatur
collective I think a lot of people from
the outside get mixed up about those
sorts of things I work within the
Catholic intellectual tradition but I
work within a lot of other strains as
well I think it's cool when the Pope's
are philosophically sophisticated that
you know I enjoy reading Benedict and
John Paul's writings because of that but
you know the role of philosophy has long
been you know something pointed out is
very important within the tradition so
you know do I think that the Pope should
be philosophically sophisticated I mean
ideally everybody should be
philosophically sophisticated right
so that that's you know that's good
le experience by itself is not science
Edmund Husserl what does this mean to
some I don't know what it means to some
you know simply reflecting on our
experience so some people think
phenomenology is just like documenting
our experience I'm doing the
phenomenological you know analysis no
you're just writing down what happened
to you a police report is not a
phenomenological description so there
there's that part right it was real
wanted things to be rigorous so that's
probably what he's going on there let's
see Nealon Annie what do I think of G
Jack's ideology
you mean the ideology that G Jack
himself espouses G Jack is a Marxist of
sorts or already mean his critique of
ideology or I think sometimes it's very
difficult to figure out what G Jack is
is saying that's that's sometimes a
problem what I do like about Gigi jack
is he's willing to take ideas and run
far with them
Andres Kolak opinion on Nietzsche's
critique of Socrates cunning self
deprecation and dialogues used to
deceive his interlocutor so they say all
they think well Nietzsche has much more
critique of Socrates irony than that
that's a useful function
he draws them out I mean Kierkegaard
says the same thing - it's this is not
something really unique to Nietzsche you
know you won't you want to get people to
tell you what they think try to get them
to be either witness for themselves
right to explain their position
Aristotle by the way thought that
Socrates in his irony was going a little
bit too far he uses as an example in the
nick of McCann ethics Kyle do I think a
certain amount of polarization is
necessary in discourse necessary no
inevitable yes and that stems more from
I would say it stems more from our vices
than from the virtue that we've managed
to cultivate and it's very easy easy for
a lot of people to think that they're
there what they perceive as their virtue
is justifying their their polarization
or their the trenchant position they're
taking when it's really coming out of
out of some sort of vise crypto coin how
am i doing what's the bit what's the
most radical philosophy texts that made
a big impact on my life that's a tough
one the most radical philosophy texts
that made a big impact on my life um
well you know I went through these
phases and one of the phases I went
through was a asar trian phase and my
nose relying on Being and Nothingness
and and his other you know sort of
novels and stuff like that and it was
very uncompromising about nobody gets to
ever excuse anything you know we are
what what we choose to be and I remember
actually making a prospective graduate
student for essay you cry and in an
argument with him and then he you went
somewhere else hears from Arquette and
he we were talking about poverty and and
I was you know arguing with him about
like you know what what you could do in
terms of fixing it so all right
Jake is a nice thing here about question
Kyle Howie was La Rochefoucauld rallying
against what's now commonly referred to
as virtue signaling and his maxims maybe
I mean depends on what we mean by virtue
signalling I think people are kind of
vague about that because it's a buzzword
and I mean it's nice to see that both
right and left now use it but you know
he was really he was going against
hypocrisy right and why do we need a
word like virtue signaling why not just
say somebody is a hypocrite because
people need to feel cool and that's what
you know calling things by new terms
gives you a lot of the time all right
Riley what do I think about
post-modernism do I think it's a good
thing so many college students take
post-modernism as a default perspective
or is this a conservative boogeyman it's
a conservative bogeyman there's no such
there's no one thing called
post-modernism
and most of the people talking about
post-modernism haven't read any of the
literature they've read to summaries and
usually you know it's about how terrible
Foucault was or something like that
I'd love it if we'd like put that that
term on ice for a while but you know
then people would find some other one to
complain about like cultural Marxism
right or all sorts of other silly stuff
I don't think many college students take
post-modernism as a default perspective
because they're not that advanced
they're not that complex they take a
motive ISM in ethics
I think MacIntyre is completely correct
but they don't just take a motive ISM
sort of their parents so to the most of
their professors sort of the most of the
people complaining about them as sort of
a default cultural perspective but
that's different than post-modernism so
yeah I think most most conservatives are
actually a motive is when it comes down
to it as well as our most liberals all
right let's see
oh it's three o'clock and I'm gonna have
to get to filming soon so let me just
grab a couple
quick things that I could answer and I'm
not gonna do any of the like what do you
think about this person what do you
think about this person ones for that
here's a good one
this is a great way to bring this to a
close since I was you know supposed to
be talking about student success so
there's from - what is a good way to
shift attitude attitude for introductory
courses that they will feel less boring
after you have the basic familiarity
they offer so that is a great question
how do you change your attitude towards
the introductory course that you're
taking and and let's sort of like deepen
it let's say you've got a professor and
the professor half the time doesn't know
what he or she's talking about and
they're kind of a jerk and they they
have a boring way of lecturing and you
know there's all sorts of times in the
class really like man you know you could
have done this yeah you know you had a
softball coming - you could have knocked
it out of the park and so it's kind of
disappointing I would say realize that
that nothing is holding you back from
studying the things that you want to
study
nothing you know if you're introduced to
some Plato there's nothing that says
that you can't go on and read more Plato
than the instructor is having you read
right if you won't write about it on the
paper that he or she assigns you but
there's nothing keeping you from
following up all these different threads
and you don't you know you don't have to
feel that you have to do with Plato it
might be a thread about I don't know
can't or it might be a thread about
Han Arendt but there's nothing
preventing you from from doing that you
live in a extremely fortunate time in
that and that we have access to vast
libraries at our fingertips even just on
our our phones right so don't take the
instructor and what that person is doing
or the boringness of the class or any of
that sort of stuff
is the
Paul mark of or the indication for
yourself about what philosophy has to
provide you or offer you instead you
know exercise some agency follow up on
your own and and see what you can make
of it because then it's good then you're
gonna have a grounding and you know the
class doesn't end for you when the
semester ends it continues on and on and
on and eventually you get to the point
where your education is the larger
context and the classes are just little
nodes in it and that education will
continue long after you leave the
university the other thing I would say
is see if you can find some other people
in your class that want to be challenged
as well and you know have coffee with
them or go out for drinks or have a meal
or hang out with them forming
friendships forming relationships with
your fellow students is an important
part of your schooling it's something
that that you know that's what it has to
offer you otherwise you could just be
doing it at home reading it at home and
watching somebody lecture right and that
that will provide you with with some
some additional ideas some some
sustenance and maybe you can develop
into a genuine friendship which is one
of the greatest joys of human life right
so that's my my advice hopefully that
can help you shift attitude and yeah so
that's what I'm gonna leave off I'll do
another one of these later this month
but I'll do that on Facebook live so you
want to check the Facebook page for that
my patreon supporters know when it's
coming up already everyone also find out
the day of and that's pretty much it for
me I have to get back to filming and
then I got to do some grading so I'm
almost done with these classes I can't
wait to be finished
with the semester so alright have a
great night or evening or day or morning
wherever you happen to be